84 ans cet homme et son épouse quittent
leurs maisons de cramât torse pour fuir
la guerre tu seras
direction l'ouest de l'ukraine et son
calme relatif
leur fille marina elle a choisi de
rester
ça a été une décision très difficile
je pense que c'est peut-être la dernière
fois que je les vois
c'est nécessaire j'ai vécu et où vont
aller les gens comme les parents de
marina ils sont des centaines à se
presser sur le quai de cette gare des
vieillards des enfants des familles les
autorités de kiev ont affrété ce train
pour leur permettre de fuir la région
je ne suis pas parti avant parce que je
ne voulais pas quitter la maison ma
femme est partie en mai mais ces
derniers jours les banques tomber jour
et nuit tout le monde est parti j'étais
presque seul dans ma rue ma femme
m'appelle tous les jours
pars pars donc je me suis décidée
aujourd'hui
500 kilomètres plus à l'ouest les
déplacés sont accueillis par des
médecins des psychologues mais aussi la
vice première ministre qui supervise les
opérations irina verrait tchouk veut
convaincre les civils restant de quitter
la zone certaines personnes disent par
exemple qu'elles n'ont plus de courant
depuis février nous ne devons plus
attendre nous devons convaincre tout le
monde d'évacuer nous devons encore
évacué cinquante mille enfants de bach
mouthe crama torse l'audience toute la
partie qui n'est pas sans occupation
selon les autorités de kiev il resterait
près de deux cent vingt mille personnes
à évacuer dans le donbass